our next speaker
is a longtime nyr speaker
there is so much i could say about him i
think we all
know all about him i could praise him i
could laud him
um but since he's coming on stage next
and i've praised him a lot of them so
many times
i was going to say we are all very
excited and very fortunate to have
yet again for the fifth time at this
conference
dr andrew gellman well his music will be
playing in a second
hopefully well should i start while
we're waiting for that
um all right well we might just have to
introduce him without a song i apologize
we're not getting his walk on music
oh too much going my computer i
apologize no walk on music
but i'll just push him understand
passively perceive the world we actively
generate there you go
so perception figuring out what's there
has to be a process of
some things can you yeah can people hear
me now
like you turned off that goofy other
thing okay that that previous talk was
so inspiring
i i think like just
like the amazing things that people can
do now that we haven't even
like hadn't even thought about uh before
i was talking with someone the other day
i i felt that the year
around the year 2010 was peak base
uh because that was by by then we were
able
to fit a lot of models and understand
what we were doing
uh but that was before all this deep
learning stuff came that that is
is so powerful and now is it's the most
popular thing
and of course there's room for different
methods out there but i i just want to
just i really appreciate like the kind
of work that everybody's doing that
the kind of the hive mind out there um
in stan we use auto death it's good to
hear about autodesk
and i heard about bob carpenter and i
heard about automatic differentiation
from a blog comment that we i blogged on
something related and a commenter talked
about it
and it was kind of counter-intuitive
like it seems like you can you can do
derivatives using the formula but
but you could do them you can always do
numerical derivatives
why would you want to do autodiff it
seems like if you have a 100 dimensional
function then you can compute the
numerical derivative by just
evaluating the function 101 times and
then and then subtracting
so people said well autodiff is faster
and it was hard to imagine how something
could be faster than
like than the dimensionality of the
problem itself but actually when you
have functions like exponentials
uh the computations are such that you
don't have to repeat the hard
computations in each dimension
that was just just kind of an amazing
insight one of these things that once
you realize it changes how you think
about things
and that was from a commenter um
and then it got incorporated into so
many other things
now regarding deep learning a few years
ago i was at a conference
at columbia and it was all about our big
data
stuff uh we're trying to impress people
so somebody came up and said i work in
in biology and in biology we have
um megabytes gigabytes of data
and then someone came up and said well
i'm from astronomy
and in astronomy we have petabytes of
data and then
the next person came up and they had
some connection with the intelligence
community and images and and they had
like whatever comes after that
exabytes or you know googles of data and
then i got up and i said well i'm in
political science so
we have we have megabytes of questions
but we only have about 20 data points
and so we actually can we actually have
to do a lot of modeling because that's
the only way to go about it um recently
i've been thinking
we've been thinking a lot about
forecasting that the upcoming
presidential election
and there just haven't been that many
presidential elections
uh sometimes we have questions about 95
intervals
it's not even clear what a 95 interval
means
uh in the sense that that would mean
you're wrong
every 20 cases which would mean
in every 80 years you'd be off once so
what does it mean to talk about
i'm not even going to have an 80-year
career right so what does it mean to
talk about intervals they're supposed to
be
off once every 80 years well when they
talk about the
100-year floods then you can say well
here's a 100-year flood it's supposed to
happen only one every 100 years
but we have smaller floods so we can we
can scale that up
and so maybe one way that we can
understand 90
intervals for 95 percent intervals is by
by thinking about
50 intervals it's it's challenging
though
um so what i want to talk about today
is the gap between what we're doing
and what we think we're doing and also
the gap between
what we think we're doing and what we
want to be doing
so this is the our conference and our
what what is our as a programming
environment
it's supposed to bridge that gap to some
extent right
r is not supposed to be the fastest
thing
r is supposed to be the thing that
matches your programming
closest to what you would do as a data
analyst
nowadays you could say i mean i've
certainly heard people say
i hate r but i use it because that's
what everybody else uses
but that's not fundamentally what makes
r r
r originally was not what everybody else
used earth predecessor s
was not originally what everybody else
used it are
gained popularity for legitimate reasons
um
and the popularity so if we're going to
be at an our conference
let's think hard about this gap and what
that gap means
so let me start with the story so a a
few months ago
uh the country uh was being wrapped by a
um a novel virus um
which i guess i i heard from the
government that it's pretty much been
resolved a few months ago but
but as of march it was considered it was
considered to be a major concern
i think that was before they reopened
the churches for easter and all the
stuff that happened since then
there we we were very worried and
i got a call from somebody i knew and
he said he knew this guy he's a doctor
and he's trying some
treatment for coronavirus patients and
he want like they want to do it a
clinical trial
and this was it's one of these uh drugs
that already exists it's being used to
treat malaria patients you can
the way it works is you can treat them
off label so you can just try it out
right away you don't have to worry about
phase one
phase two phase three all that they want
to design the experiment
um and this was in the early stages when
they were like
hospitals in new jersey were just full
of people who were were dying of
of the stuff right and so
i talked to the guy the doctor he said
yeah we want we um
are expecting the effect of the drug to
be to reduce
to reduce the death rate by 25
percentage points it's like not
like so 25 percentage points that's a
lot he said well yeah you know some
people did a study saying it would
reduce death rates by 50 percentage
points
but i think that's a bit optimistic so
i'm just saying 25
so how big a sample size do we need so
you can do the computation
um and um you get about 120 i think 126
patients so
like half in each group um
and then i i actually i i apologize
because this is
i'm going to tell you something which we
call a findman story which is a story
that you tell that makes you look good
and other people look bad
and i i shouldn't do that and i think if
it were a little more artful i would
have
changed the roles around so i was the
fool and somebody else
next time i tell it i'll work on that so
forgive me i'm gonna actually tell
how it happened um but sorry so
i asked him i said do you think what if
the effect is less than
25 percentage points like what if it's
only 10 percentage points
well then like you then you need like a
thousand people
in your study right like uh so
maybe you should do that like there's a
lot of patients coming through like
and it's like how small an effect could
matter
like if it's one if the effect is one
percentage point i mean sure it's great
to save a life now and then but
it wouldn't be so newsworthy we're
trying all sorts of things but
10 points that's still newsworthy that's
still important right he said yeah
that would be still worth it um but
he thought the effect was 20 to 25
percentage points
well obviously it has to be contingent
right the effect can't be 25 percentage
points unless the actual death rate is
at least 25
in the control group right so we're
talking about this particular acute
setting
um how large could it be so he said no i
think
it's really the drug does a lot so then
i said
um but drug might not work right so yeah
of course it might not work i can be
wrong that's why we're doing this study
in the first place right
he didn't delude himself that he had was
omniscient
at all so but then if it could work
how are you so sure the effect is 25 so
here's
this is like the the tyranny of notation
or something
right the what does it mean to say the
effect is 25 percentage points if it's
length and death
what it means is that there's 25 of the
people
who would have died if you hadn't given
them the treatment but the treatment
saves them or maybe there's 35 percent
of people like that and then there's 10
percent who the treatment kills or
whatever but for simplicity say it's
okay so the whole point of the treatment
is
you want for the treatment to be
effective you want those people
so there's two kinds of people or three
kinds of people in the world right the
four kinds there's people who would die
and do either treatment the people would
live under either treatment
and the people who would die under one
living root but let let's
the people you want in your study are
the ones who would die
under the control and live in the
treatment and so
what you're saying if you think the
treatment effect is 25 percentage points
is that you think that 25 of the people
in your study are that kind of people
but once you accept that well
it could be less right i mean it just
depends who's in the damn study like it
has to
it must depend on how far the the
disease is advanced
and so forth so of course the effect
could be 10 percentage points if it
could be 25 percentage points but
the in in this sense getting back to the
gap between what we're doing
and the gap between what we think we're
doing
is people are set up to think that
they're
that they're trying to estimate a
parameter
but what you're really doing is what
you're really
we're trying to do is figure out who are
the people in the study
so it's like a completely different
different question
so now with that story as
as background um let me get back to the
title of the talk which is
truly open science so open science is
more than data sharing
replication pre-registration partial
pooling and version control
those are all important parts of data
science open science
obviously data sharing is important
replication
pre-registration is is an important part
of data science
having a record of what you've done
partial pooling is an important part of
data science open science
this partial pooling is generalizing
from what you've
learned to what you're interested in
right that's
that's very important to be kind of
upfront about what you're doing
and of course without version control we
are truly nothing
right um but open science is more than
that
and doing statistics right is more than
swapping bayesian methods for p values
or for that matter swapping deep
learning and cross-validation for
p-values
to resolve the larger problems of the
push of button take a pill model of
science
engineering and policy we need to move
toward collaboration between researchers
data analysts and people who design
studies
and work with the people whose data are
being collected
um now often that means that we it's
like
you know it's often social engineering
that's important right
so often what that means is that the
like the people the subject matter
people have to
think less like statisticians sometimes
so like the
doctors actually dealing with patients
he should be the one telling me
that he's looking for the people who
will get cured and the people who want
right like he's
he's doing the abstraction in
inappropriately which means that we're
not working well
as a team right so doing this having
this kind of collaboration
requires the ability to simulate graph
and analyze data
using flexible platforms such as stan
and
r and all the other all the other things
out there
um now simulation i i have a
principle now that i should never
do an experiment or gather data without
simulating fake data first
right and i can i can tell you a story
of of where this happened to me um
so i was i was doing a study actually i
think i mentioned this in in the
you know our conference a few years ago
which is our study on on political
penumbras so the idea is that you you
ask people questions like
how many gay people do you know how many
close friends do you know who have been
unemployed in the past year different
things like that
and then you learn about the size of a
group uh the number of a group so
okay it's interesting to know that four
percent of americans are gay
but maybe it's even more interesting or
also interesting to know that that more
than 50 percent of americans have a
close friend or family member who's gay
i can't remember if it's 50 but
something like that
um if a group has a large penumbra
then that would suggest that it could be
politically
influential other groups such as they we
ask people how many
women do you know have had an abortion
in the past five years that is a very
small penumbra because people won't
necessarily tell you
if they've had abortion so it's that
penumbra is a function not only of the
size of a group and who people know
but also of of who tells people
about these facts but we did a study a
survey which we asked people
are where they um we asked people how
many
people did they know how many close
friends close family members and other
people they knew in different groups
and then we also asked them some
political attitudes
and you see some correlation um
unexpectedly
we followed we we did a follow-up survey
a year later
and we wanted to see whether people who
entered a penumbra
were were changing their political
attitudes on average
well you know there's a kind of causal
story there i don't want to push the
causal story too hard because
entering the penumbra is not an
externally assigned treatment
it's something that happens to you it's
a survey response
um but nonetheless there i won't get
into it here but there are reasons we
believe that we've had a certain amount
of causal identification we're
interested in this story
so what i want to do is see if you
enter let's say the gay penumbra you now
know a gay person you didn't before
are your attitudes on on certain gay
rights issues
are likely to change and so you can do a
regression
it's it's it's simple enough to do the
analysis
there's a lot of different ways of doing
analysis different ways of adjusting for
it
things and like forking paths i won't
get into that but what i want to talk
about is what i
didn't do what i should have done what i
should have done was simulate fake data
and analyze the fake data before getting
anywhere the reason why
is when all is said and done we did
estimate effects and they were
kind of like roughly two standard errors
away from zero
we have a certain amount of confidence
that they would replicate in the new
study
but the standard errors are quite large
so a typical
estimate might be an effect size
estimate of 0.1 with a standard error of
0.05 of an uncomfortably large
uncertainty so we're estimating for so
many groups not just
gays and unemployed we have 14 different
groups
um so let's break this down how do you
get an effect size
of of one it's a 0.1
so you can get an effect size of 0.1 if
you say that
these are survey questions measured on a
1 to 5 scale
and if you like what kind of changes are
we going to expect well
let's just say that
if you do change your min you might just
change by one and a one to five scale
like meeting a gay person is not going
to move you from one to five
not likely right and for that matter it
could move you in the opposite direction
right so a net movement
um wasn't going to be that much then the
other part the other part of this one to
five scale
is that um
is that most people aren't going to
change their views
because people have views they're mostly
not going to change now one way of
seeing this is that
our two our two waves of the survey were
a year apart
um how much change would you expect to
see in one year well one
of i'm bringing up this this gay right
same sex marriage
issue um in part because that was
one issue where there were big changes
so over a 20-year period support for
same-sex marriage went up from about 30
to 60 an increase of about one and a
half percentage point per year
that's huge right but then if you think
about it
one and a half percent we had two
thousand people in our survey
right so like one and a half what's one
and a half percent of 2000 people that's
30 people
right so we're getting into pretty small
sample sizes
and then if you look at entering the
number most people aren't going to enter
the number on any given year most people
are either in the number already or
they're not in the number and they're
not about to enter
right so if 10 of the people enter the
penumbra then you're talking about 200
people in your sample that you're
comparing
and then you talk about an effect of of
the small you talk about small effects
and you'll get these large standard
errors so we
we did something which is pretty common
which was we we did our analysis we
gathered our data in a kind of hopeful
way
saying we'll run our analysis and get
something good but then in retrospect
we we really barely had enough data to
find what we were trying to
find we should have realized that ahead
of time
so again this is the gap between what
we're doing and what we think we're
doing
right so what we think we're doing is
gathering data
and getting a quantitative measure of
the changes in blah blah blah
what we're actually doing is getting a
noisy measure of blah blah blah
so there's a saying so statistics is
very much about communication
in various ways right so one thing i'd
say when i teach statistical
communication
is that everyone trained in statistics
becomes a teacher
now not necessarily like my job is
teacher like that's my
job title but or jared does a lot of
teaching
and and um but but also
if you work i think this is true for all
of you in the audience that
if you are the analytics person you're
not just sharing your results with
people you're spending a lot of time
explaining not just your results but
your methods you have to explain the
methods to people and you have to really
be a teacher that
that this is people keep always coming
up to me and and telling me this
um now regardless so communication is
very important
programming is a form of communication
you're communicating with the
computer um it's said that your most
important collaborator
is you six months from now and she
doesn't answer
emails and so when you are
like when we're programming you're not
only communicating with the computer now
your computer can
communicating with the future you so
right now what was i doing right before
a few minutes before this talk
what i was doing was fitting a
hierarchical model
uh to some of some subset of these data
that i was just telling you about
to estimate over dispersion of the of
the social networks
and i programmed up like
six different models and stand like
because i broke i wrote something and it
was like
going really slowly and it wasn't
converging and then i re-parameterized
it
and then that seemed to work and it gave
results that made sense i was about to
plot the results
but then i really certain data hadn't
been combined so i combined the data and
re-ran it
now the results don't look right to me
the over-dispersion seem
too high for the for the name penumbras
because they should be close to
independent
except for maria and jose but the other
names should be
closer to independent and they're not um
like i'm doing everything wrong i mean
i'm doing like
i'm doing a master class and how not to
program right like i i
i i think that i should be stimulating
fake data from my model
this time not to understand the power of
my study
but because like if if i'm getting
computing results that don't make sense
you want to separate
from what you want to separate whether
it's your
model not fitting the data or your
program not converging or there being a
coding era like it's very easy to do
that by simulating fake data just i just
still not in the habit of doing it i'm
barely in the habit of haranguing other
people to do it
that's the first step in any any
workflow is to
harangue other people to do things and
then you start realizing you should you
should do it yourself
and so i'm not there um
and i'm trying to i'm trying to work on
it so in that sense i'm trying to apply
some of the principles of open science
to to what i'm doing
this relates to something so
when i was um
way back when um like i i was
before i was a statistician or a
statistics student i was a physics
student i worked in physics labs
i wasn't very good at physics so i i
didn't understand it very well
but i so i stopped doing it but i was
kind of good at experimental physics
because that involved a lot of data
analysis
and and i so that's sort of how i ended
up doing
what i'm doing but one thing i remember
is that
i'd be making a lot of graphs
and i quickly learned that when i was
making presentation
graphs for others it was helpful for me
to have
subtleties that i would have in my own
graphs for myself so like
as much as i would think well no other
people want a simple story
actually for me what other people wanted
was a kind of
rough story right they wanted me to like
like if my story were a voice they would
want it to be like kathleen turner not
whitney houston right like they'd want
the kind of roughness to it
and so they people liked a graph that
showed aspects of the model that didn't
fit and it's
it's kind of a fine it's kind of a cheap
trick but like they say like if you want
to convince somebody of something
you tell them a lie and they catch you
out on it and then they're like okay
well there he was lying so i think he's
telling the truth now
so similarly with with data like we make
a graph
and we say look the model is not perfect
look at this
then maybe people are more likely to
trust the parts
that that they do understand which i do
not think is a
dirty trick i mean i think that this is
the honest way to perceive
but my point is that presentation
graphics
are were like i wanted to apply the
principles of statistics
statistical graphics conversely i find
i found very early on and i always teach
this
that if you're only making graphs for
yourself
you should apply principles of
presentation graphics you should make
the axes
label the axes make things pretty um
and make things clear give good titles
because you are communicating to
yourself also
um i think if i want to give you one
message that you could take home
from this entire talk i guess i i buried
it at like the 30 minute mark when
nobody's paying attention anymore
uh so get off your email for a second
you get off facebook
yeah i know that was pretty horrible
what politician x said about politician
why that
that was scandalous it's the scandal of
the week we'll take a break from that
for a second because i'm telling you the
most important thing
and this is in my books too but i'm
telling you now because you weren't
paying attention
the most important thing is to put
multiple graphs on the page
and so you can see more right real
estate
it's everything right and
i learned that so but people don't
always realize that because they think
of
oh that's for presentations i'm just
doing stuff
so this is the same thing about the
principles of open science like it's a
fractal right
you should be open science all the way
through so i should be doing replication
and fake data even when i'm fitting
every model i fit
i should build the scaffolding every
time i shouldn't just assume things are
going to work
and i don't do that i don't always do
that myself
um so
we we have a saying in
in open science that honesty and
transparency are not enough
um and and that kind of means
two things i mean honesty and
transparency are
are important but what we say this
partly because like sometimes like in
the open science
movement people will say oh so and so
they're using questionable research
practices
or they're therapy hacking whatever
they're doing this bad stuff
and people have this reaction like no
i'm not doing this bad stuff like i'm a
good person
and so like for one thing you shouldn't
act like people are bad people just
because they do bad science i mean isaac
newton did some bad science too
you know like that's just the way it is
bad science is part of science right
um and even if everything you do is bad
science it doesn't mean you're a bad
person like
i'm really bad at basketball doesn't
mean i'm a bad person right
okay and so but then the so part of it
is you just it's just
wrong to kind of accuse people of
of doing stuff that's like immoral if
just just because they're doing stuff
that's hurtful
right but then the second thing is the
flip side is that you can't let people
off the hook because then they're like
oh i'm not immoral i'm not a bad person
therefore i'm not doing bad science like
no no you can be you can be a wonderful
human being
and even not just a wonderful human
being you can
you can do pre-registration and and and
data sharing and github and all that
and still do bad science right just like
the econometricians they
all focus so much on identification then
the trouble was that once people
were doing identification they didn't
realize you could still do bad science
you know identification and bad science
right
anything fits with bad science that's
that's fine so we have to be
we have to be aware of that um but if
you think about
these cases where what i'm calling
science is superficially open but not
truly open is that people are not
mapping this gap between what they're
doing and what we think we're doing
now let me conclude i guess i have like
five minutes here
um with an example um so it's a recent
example
of which is election forecasting
and the first time i ever did election
forecasting was in 1992
the story actually starts four years
before that um
that um
[Music]
scientist
is a migration dukakis election victory
party in
1988 michael dukakis um did not
he was the democratic nominee for
president in 1988 and so
he did not actually win um
so the tickets to his victory
celebration or just a historical
amusement i didn't actually go to the
party uh but i was
i was work i had a colleague um who
political science professor who had
these tickets
um we did not it was months before the
election and dukakis
was comfortably ahead in the polls and
my colleague told me that
i should that he showed me the tickets
and said he laughed and he said
dukakis is going to lose i said what do
you mean he said well i've read some
books by political scientists and
you can forecast the election based on
the economy and
and uh presidential popularity and stuff
like that and it looks like a good year
for the republicans
and my colleague was right so of course
that had a big influence on me
we wrote some stuff about elections
being predictable
so to do this we needed to make election
forecasting model
so i did that we computed all sorts of
fun
pop probabilities it was before the
internet and all that
so somehow i couldn't get people weren't
really interested in all this
forecasting stuff
like it was a very niche area but in
more recent years the election
forecasting has become very popular so
things have changed i don't i don't
quite know why
um but my colleague um elliott morris
and um my coach at the economist and my
student merlin heidemanns and i
have been working on uh we constructed a
model that we fit and stand
to uh forecast the 2020 presidential
election
so we think that joe biden has like a
90 chance of winning
the model combined several pieces of
information
state polls national polls as a model
for non-sampling areas and polls
is a fundamental based forecast which it
uses
prior it has previous election results
in the states
uh and it has a kind of complicated not
that complicated but it has a time
series model for um uh for how the polls
and public opinions change over time
and we do have it on github uh probably
the most open thing about it is that
there were three of us working on it so
we kept trying to poke holes in it and
find problems then we published it and
then after was out we
some people had some issues and we
looked carefully and it turned out we
had a bunch of coding errors and things
where we again our program was not doing
what it
what we thought it was doing and it is i
think it is a weakness of a lot of
statistical methods
including what we do and i i think it's
a weakness of a lot of deep learning
methods too
is that they don't really have this like
future
weakness is good it's like future
research um they don't really
have good ways of checking or
understanding this gap between what
you're doing and what you think you're
doing
so there is some research on
interpretable machine learning
but it's kind of like coming from the
perspective of yeah you're doing the
right thing and you just have to explain
it to like the sales people
right and that's not really what i'm
talking about i'm really saying like
understanding these gaps and i've done
some research on model checking and
dave bly columbia has done some research
on posterior predictive checking too
um but again it's kind of that's coming
across as like yeah we know what we're
doing but it might not fit the data so
let's fix that
um not we're not really fully addressing
that gap
it's something that that we need to do
um
currently a lot of the gap is being
addressed in the social
arena that our model is out there so
people can criticize it
but to be honest like you put your code
on github and most people aren't going
to look at your code i mean
there's lots of air we had errors in our
code that were sitting there for a month
or two and nobody noticed at all
um so you don't like people will find
easy
people will work on easy problems for
free but it's sometimes hard to get them
to work on
on hard problems um
so my message to all of you
to conclude um is that
you have to that
when you when we talk about tools such
as r and stan
these are expressive tools they allow
you to
they allow you to express yourself to
like move in ways that you could not
easily move
um by yourself um
and we gradually think of yourself think
of you whoever you are
how first you could do like you learned
how to do simple things in the computer
at some point you learned regression and
you didn't really understand it
maybe you were doing stepwise regression
or something
you develop certain you you learn things
by
like trying out like templates like
imitating somebody else's
tools and then gradually you got used to
things
and and and how that went and imagine
yourself as a continuing to this so we
we talk about the exploration
exploitation trade-off well
you should always be exploring if you're
85 years old
you should be exploring not optimizing
there's always room for exploration
people are always
optimizing too soon okay so you're going
to be continuing to learn
how can you be a more effective
colleague teammate
um and how can you more more effectively
help the world
as as a data analyst or as as as a
programmer
of course the way that there's two ways
you get better at the things you already
know how to do and you learn
new skills right and how do you how do
you do that
um i think if you can focus on that gap
and
i i i accept that this talk was more
conceptual
rather than like constructive partly
because i didn't really realize i was
going to talk about this gap until like
five minutes into the talk so i didn't i
didn't prepare this
but if you think about this if you think
about
where this gap is and how you can build
your own tools
to to solve that i think you will become
a better learner um and i think you'll
be you'll be a better
a better colleague and problem solver so
that's why
i'd like to help you do that and and i
feel like and
i think part of it if you think that's
like the third leg of the stool because
part of it is that the ideas of open
science and good practices which
are is like you know both good and bad
in terms of has good and bad aspects of
that
and then part of it are actual
statistical or data analytic tools
tricks that you learn but then this
third part is being very
self-aware of what you want what's
happening
what you're expecting to see uh it's
like applying ideas such as
pre-registration and replication
to your own learning process so i think
if you can introspect like that
you can you can become a more effective
problem solver and a more effective
teammate i hope that happens for all of
you
okay everyone normally we have
a no question thing at this conference
that's why you keep it moving
but only two people have ever taken
questions at this conference
vivian peng the very first year she
finished a little early so i threw her
back on stage
and andrew has so
there was one question that came in
earlier and i'm sorry if this is
a uh dousing flames on a fire
but we want your take on nate silver and
538 forecasting
oh i i i wrote something on our blog
today about that i thought yeah i think
well as i wrote there i think what he's
doing is very similar to what we do
because as there's a principle of house
stern
which is the most important thing about
a statistical method is not what it does
with the data but what data it uses
so you had staples you have national
polls you have some fundamentals based
forecast
you have a model for how these things
are changing
a model for polling error and you put
that together and you have
idiosyncratic factors so we tried to
isolate it how are they different
so i think uh his fundamental space
forecast is different from ours um i
think his is a little more informed by
2016
and and for uh ours is kind of more
influenced by
like economic factors so were
our fundamentals based forecast would be
biden getting 54
of the two-party vote nate is more like
52 percent which is
what happened which is what happened in
2016.
um i kind of like our poll aggregation
approach better than his
partly because we're cheating we're
using bayesian methods and he's like
trying to like
come up with a bunch of clever ideas one
after the other so
like i feel like he can't win that one
because he's just trying desperately
at best he'll reinvent bay's rule um
i don't think that's really gonna gonna
work um he has
like i we um i don't quite know how he
deals with non-sampling error i like how
we deal with that
um it's it's hard to say because
there's uh i felt that looking at the
percent
the percentage uh chance that someone
wins it's hard to know what to do with
that
our 95 interval for biden's fit share of
the two-party vote is 50
to 54 so like do i
50 sorry 50 to 58
so like well what if biden got 49 like
would i be so
surprised of the two-party vote well
like i don't know like you know maybe
like would i bet
95 it's hard to answer these questions
um like it seems like biden could get 60
of the two-party vote like it doesn't
seem completely impossible that the
republicans could abandon trump
on the other hand they haven't abandoned
him yet like you can kind of go in
circles about this which i i just think
kind of demonstrates that
the limitations of these forecasts like
ultimately these forecasts
i'll take a kind of two key line on it
and say
these forecasts are products of data i
mean they're human products they're
little bridges we're building they're
not
truly the probability that someone would
have like would i
bet on this in some way if i want to
decide what to bat
i don't believe the betting markets i
think undervalue biden i think the
betting markets are too informed by
2016.
there's a principle of bill james which
is that the alternative
to um good statistics is not no
statistics
the alternative to good statistics is
bad statistics
he said that because of there would be
sports writers who would say hey bill
james stop doing all your fancy
number crunching i just i want to base
things on more qualitative features
and bill james pointed out that they
were basing them on qualitative features
like somebody hit 350 in fenway park
once and things like that
people were using the numbers they just
weren't they weren't thinking about them
seriously
um they were using the numbers as uh
words
in in as he put it so similarly i feel
oh actually the you know people in the
betting markets might feel like they're
being super
conservative by not favoring biden too
much they might think that they're being
really hard-headed what i'm
what i would say is they're partially
pulling towards 2016.
and maybe that's right
i don't think something about that
speaking externally if i were
not me and i were not nate and i were
just someone else coming at this from
the outside what would i say
i'd say well i think that economist
model has some sophisticated poll
averaging
i would guess that they do a pretty good
job at
of um not track combining the
information efficiently from state and
national pulse
point in our favor uh point number two
is that there's a million polls
so that point in our favor is not such a
big deal we're making very efficient use
of data that there's tons of
uh nate's uh model are his you know his
his model is different from ours well
gee you know this economist people know
a lot but like nate knows a lot too
like you know maybe split the difference
i'm not going to split the difference i
kind of like what we did but if i
weren't me then i'd probably do that
you're silent jared i can't hear you
should we be aggregating your two
predictions
well i wouldn't do that like i but but
like you know maybe you should
like it's it's it's it's like it's hard
to say i mean we're not
so people say like well what if uh you
know what if one of the candidates
they're old guys what if they get a
stroke and they're replaced by their
running mates like well that would make
a difference that's not really in our
model
like well it's implicitly in the error
term but it's never happened before
but it could like it it's it is
it is hard to draw the line i mean it's
like
there's two ways to it's like it's hard
to be completely kind of
objective and purely numbers based
because we do care about the outcome but
at the same time it's hard to be
completely
it's hard to give a total probability
answer like so i
joke to the reporter at one point like
well this doesn't account for
possible meteor strikes right well
that's that's kind of silly but
like as i said there's
i don't think there's a precise answer i
i was getting on nate's case low because
his 95
interval for florida said that biden was
going to get somewhere between
43 and 59 of the vote in florida
it's hard for me to picture biden only
getting 43 percent of the vote in
florida like it seems so low
but like i mean that's the story is
somehow the economy is
booming back and people like that or
things are variable or something happens
in florida
something says there is variation from
state to state
part of the reason we have kind of
narrower intervals is because
in the era of political polarization
things are less variable than they used
to be
like you can kind of talk things around
in circles
it's hard to hold it all in your head at
once like it's like florida 43
in florida that seems too low so like
our lower bound for florida
our 95 interval goes from like 46
for biden to something else right i
could see by getting 46
in florida but not 43. so i don't know i
think maybe nate's doing something not
quite right in terms of state
correlations like maybe his states
aren't correlated enough and so then you
but like you're getting these wide
uncertainties
um i'm not quite i'm not quite sure
exactly um
cool thank you so much the comment
section was blowing up while you were
talking it was a lot of fun for everyone
thank you once again for giving us an
outstanding talk and
we look forward to next year you're
already booked by the way okay well
thanks for the opportunity to uh
is it people i just wouldn't otherwise
reach
who work in who work in you know warrant
students and or
diverse people in so many ways so thank
you jared for organizing this and i'll
see you absolutely
thank you all right everyone with
that we have our first afternoon break
let's be back here be a little bit
shorter because we had a little extra
fun time with andrew
everyone be back in the seats at 2 35
i'm gonna go get a refill
and everyone will see you soon have a
good one